5 août 1952 un couple d'Anglais et leur
fille retrouvée assassinés Gaston
Dominici dans la ferme se situe à
proximité du lieu de Crimée accusé de ce
triple meurtre et condamné à mort bien
que sa culpabilité n'est pas été
clairement établie demain 1er février
des étudiants en droit de l'Université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
vont rouvrir ce dossier au tribunal de
grande instance de la cité royale
j'accueille donc sur le plateau aurorson
bonsoir et Marie aube également vous
êtes toutes les deux responsables de
cette reconstitution qui se déroule
demain vous êtes en deuxième et en
première année c'est bien ça cette étude
de droit alors tout d'abord ce procès
pour vous qui remonte tout de même à
1950 1952 ça représente quoi c'est un
vrai cas d'école justement c'est un gars
qui est très intéressant parce que
justement il y a du doute de celui c'est
vraiment ça qui nous intéresse c'est
essayer de savoir si aujourd'hui comme
il y a 50 ans est-ce que les gens
pensent de la même manière est-ce que
de cette affaire c'est difficile
d'approche justement un cas comme
celui-ci comment vous avez travaillé
pour le reconstituer ce procès on a
commencé à travailler en octobre en fait
et on a monté tout un dossier autour de
cette affaire donc c'est vrai qu'en
lisant l'affaire on sait tout de suite
dit c'est lui mais en plongeant plus
dans l'affaire on remarque qu'il y a des
témoignages qui concordent pas il y a
des il y a des profs qui sont absents ou
qui n'ont pas servi à prouver la
culpabilité ou justement l'innocence de
Gaston Dominici donc c'est vraiment ça
qui permet de lancer l'affaire et de la
présenter aux étudiants comme étant une
affaire qui n'a pas été clairement
résolue vous connaissez déjà cette
affaire avant de commencer ses études de
droit vous aviez déjà entendu ce nom
Dominicis a évoqué quelque chose
après bon on n'avait pas non plus
cherché plus loin c'était juste mais
comment est venu justement cette affaire
sur la table quand vous avez décidé de
reconstituer c'est fait par
l'association juristributs depuis 5-6
ans reconstitue différents procès il y
avait le procès ranuccident dernier que
nous avions suivi d'ailleurs sur cette
antenne là le cas de municipale
c'est un projet qui nous a été proposé
donc par le bureau de l'association donc
par les responsables de l'association et
après nous on a parmi plusieurs autres
projets et nous après nous avons essayé
de trouver le projet qui nous
intéressait plus donc justement toujours
au niveau du doute au niveau de du fait
que ce soit intéressant ou non la
reconstitution qui aura lieu donc demain
à Versailles est-ce que ce sera possible
d'y assister d'ailleurs pour le grand
public tout à fait tout le monde et
c'est à partir de 12h30 là on voit
quelques images de préparation on se
rendra tout à l'heure justement dans les
locaux de l'université nous avons suivi
votre petite préparation pour tout ça
parce que le but véritablement c'est une
mise en situation c'est de sortir du
cadre purement théorique c'est bien ça
c'est pour ça que vous le faites cet
exercice
c'est les études de droits peuvent
paraître sombre et un peu massifs
énormément de choses à assimiler et les
études enfin la reconstruction de procès
permet aux étudiants de vraiment voir
comment se déroule un procès parce que
même s'il y a des séances libres on
pense pas forcément y aller on n'a pas
forcément le temps c'est une masse de
travail conséquente et voilà ça leur
permet vraiment de s'immerger dedans et
de voir comment ça se déroule et déjà
justement découvert des choses que vous
n'imaginez pas sur des roulements de
procès toute l'organisation les rôles de
chacun que ce soit en prison la courte
ou bêtement bah moi au début je pensais
qu'il y avait un juge comme aux
États-Unis et que ça s'appelait pas au
président de la cour où le rôle de
divers parties l'importance que peut
avoir le témoignage de chaque témoin ou
autre même les jurés leur importance
comment ils étaient choisis c'est vrai
que c'est très intéressant la
reconstitution qui se déroule donc
demain à Versailles et vous pourrez y
assister mais pour l'instant voici
quelques images de la répétition du
travail préparatoire de ces étudiants de
l'université
l'affaire Gaston Dominici l'histoire de
ce triple meurtre d'un couple d'anglais
et de leur fille revu et peut-être
corrigé par des étudiants de droit de
l'Université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
c'est le projet lancé par l'association
juriste tribune tous les ans une
reconstitution de procès est proposé on
choisit une une affaire qui dont le
jugement a été sombre obscur dans le
sens où les preuves ne montrent pas
vraiment la culpabilité ou l'innocence
de l'accusé et donc en fait notre rôle
c'est de vraiment faire tout un dossier
pour pour essayer de trouver les petites
erreurs pour essayer vraiment de
construire quelque chose de solide pour
montrer aux étudiants comment se déroule
un procès la préparation commence dès le
mois d'octobre dans un premier temps
trouver toutes les preuves et les
informations liées à ce dossier on se
base surtout sur Internet on essaie
surtout de trouver ça qu'on trouve pas
tout ce qu'on veut par exemple pour les
procès-verbaux d'audition de toutes les
personnes on a réussi à en trouver
quelques-uns comme celui d'accusé celui
d'un des témoins mais c'est vrai qu'on
n'a pas les pièces ne sont pas toutes
ouvertes c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
aller voir les scellés par exemple des
fois on nous demande l'épreuve et ce que
vous allez les vrais preuve bah non
c'est des preuves bah qu'on essaie de
retranscrire au mieux on n'a pas un
pantalon dans cette affaire là et c'est
un pantalon qui vient de chez nous mais
c'est le but c'est vraiment d'essayer de
retranscrire au mieux pour les étudiants
dans un deuxième temps il faut préparer
les rôles de charger de travaux dirigés
joue le rôle des avocats le président du
jury est représenté par un professeur
les jurés sont des personnes extérieures
à l'université et des étudiants de droit
eux sont les témoins on est nouveau dans
en première année donc on connaît rien
et donc là on touche un peu à tout on
augmente nos capacités à réfléchir sur
le droit et donc ça c'est une ouverture
en plus le procès débute à l'époque
Gaston Dominici avait été jugé coupable
et condamné à mort 61 ans plus tard le
verdict sera-t-il différent réponse
vendredi lors de la reconstitution qui
aura lieu au tribunal de grande instance
de Versailles l'an passé juristribue
avait étudié une autre affaire célèbre
le procès Ranucci les étudiants
n'avaient alors pas condamné Christian
Ranucci à la peine de mort mais à la
prison à perpétuité autre temps
autremeur se juridique
on a vu votre préparation et quelques
images du procès reconstitué l'an
dernier on le voit il y a beaucoup de
monde de mobilisés c'est très lourd
comme travail c'est très lourd et pour
nous et pour qui participent notamment
pour les témoins aussi pour les avocats
qui ont un travail derrière énorme ils
doivent travailler sur leur plaidoirie
comme un vrai procès en fait on leur
donne des délais ils ont des délais à
respecter ils ont une certaine tonne de
travail à faire qui est vraiment
importantes quel rôle vous allez tenir
demain sur la reconstitution moi je
serai vissé et moi je serais assez de du
président de la con donc vous serez
véritablement impliqué lors de la
reconstitution également et tout ça se
fait en plus on l'a pas précisé des
études parce que c'est fait par
l'association mais même si ça fait
partie prenante de votre formation à
côté il faut quand même aller en cours
il faut quand même travailler c'est bien
ça et c'est pas trop difficile de tout
vous regrettez pas de vous être engagé
là-dedans justement c'est un projet
tellement beau tellement intéressant on
a tellement envie d'être à demain on se
dit que c'est une chance formidable
qu'on a de faire ce projet donc non
absolument on regrette pas et on le
conseille vraiment à tous les étudiants
qui peuvent avoir l'occasion de
participer à un projet de la sorte vous
êtes en première année donc vous n'aviez
pas participé l'an dernier par contre en
deuxième année vous avez déjà participé
assisté l'année dernière au procès
amitié justement et c'est vraiment ça
qui m'a donné envie de d'être en charge
de ce projet cette année parce que en
voyant les images en voyant travail qui
avait été fourni en voyant la qualité de
ce qu'ils avaient fait l'année dernière
j'ai eu aucun doute et je me suis dit
allez on se lance et on s'organise ce
projet là cette année la reconstitution
du procès l'an dernier avait débouché
sur un verdict un peu différent par
rapport au cas de d'origine vous
imaginez la même chose pour demain même
s'il faut laisser la justice travailler
on le sait mais oui ce sera ce sera très
probablement une décision différente
étant donné que le contexte a changé
tout le monde ne vit plus dans les
années 50 mentalement parlant du coup
avec les nouveaux éclairs enfin les
nouveaux éclairages qui se portent sur
le sur l'affaire il se peut que très
probablement que les jurés ont une
décision différente et donc qui avait
été condamné on le rappelle un
dominicieux Gaston Dominici en 1952 et
en 1957 le président Coty avait commué
la peine et le 14 juillet 1960 c'est le
général de Gaulle qu'il avait gracié et
libéré voilà pour la petite précision
historique merci donc à toutes les deux
reconstitution de ce procès ouvert au
public demain au tribunal de grande
instance à Versailles à partir de 12h30
et puis toutes les images seront à
découvrir au début de la semaine
prochaine sur notre antenne merci
beaucoup l'actualité du jour c'est la
mobilisation des agents de la fonction
publique dans l'éducation nationale un
mouvement peut suivi dans les Yvelines
seulement 18% de grévistes nous avons
fait le tour dans l'agglomération
grève des fonctionnaires ce jeudi dans
les Yvelines dans l'éducation nationale
au total seulement 18% du personnel
était en grève il réclame une hausse de
leur salaire et prothèse contre la
suppression de poste c'est la première
grève menée par la CGT est faite du
quinquennat de François Hollande c'est
la première c'est une façon de prendre
date sur la défense des services publics
qui ont été très mal menées ces 10
dernières années et qui en dehors de
l'éducation continue à l'être dans le
projet de budget la grève est peu suivie
dans l'agglomération la plus grande
mobilisation se situe à Trappes au total
cette école ont fermé quatre maternelles
et trois primaires
avoisins-le-bretonneux seul l’école de
la pépinière n'a pas ouvert ses portes
ce matin dans les autres communes les
établissements étaient ouverts mais
certains services ne sont pas assurés à
La Verrière il n'y a pas de garderie de
restauration ni d'animation dans les
écoles du bois de l'étang et du parc
élémentaire le service minimum est en
revanche mis en place à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux car 25%
d'enseignants sont grévistes les
fonction naires étaient 5,2 millions à
être appelé à la grève ce jeudi à
travers 120 points de rassemblement